本日は
明日、14日の土曜日
15日の日曜日と
センター試験でございます
受験生の皆さん
勉強お疲れ様です
はじめしゃちょーです
えーっとこの動画はですねひとまず、受験生の皆さん、
そして
ひょっとしたら今後、大学に行きたいなとか思ってる皆！
に向けての動画でございます。
よかったら見てください
そもそも僕ですね、なんでこんな受験の動画とか受験系の動画たまに出すかと言いますと
多分僕”人生で何を一番頑張ったの？”って言われたら
間違いなく”大学受験”って答える人間です。
僕、そんな勉強できる人間じゃなかったすよ
中学校の時とかバリバリ　英語 100点中16点とかだったし
勉強いやだったんですけども
まぁそんな状況からなんとか頑張って勉強して
馬鹿なりに時間を掛ければなんとかなると思って
まぁなんとか皆さんも知ってると思うんですけど
国立大学の静岡大学に進学できた人間でございます。
なので僕、大学受験というのにすごい思い入れがあって
勉強の辛さとか受験のプレッシャーとか色んなの感じてきてるし
すっげー苦しくて孤独との闘いっていうのも知ってるので
それ苦しんでる皆さんが頑張ってるって思うと、こう何か声をかけたいなって思っちゃって
ついつい受験の季節になるとこういう動画を撮ります。
受験生の皆さんも多分当日前ですごい緊張してると思うんで
ちょっとでもね緊張がほぐれるようなお話をしようと思います
今日話すのは
僕のセンター試験当日のお話でございます
17の時センター試験出たから
22,21,20,19（年齢）
18,17
あの戦争からもう6年も経ってるのか。
間違いなく国立大学に行くような人間じゃないんですけども
まぁ勉強ゴリゴリ!!アホみたいに勉強してなんとかそこら辺まで辿り着いた
まぁそういう男がですね
必死こいて超勉強したうえで挑んだセンター試験だったので
めちゃくちゃ緊張してました当日は。
で僕、富山県出身だったんで
センター試験当日の1月めちゃくちゃ吹雪だったんですよ。
そんな悪天候のセンター試験だったんですけども
事件その①
1日目のお昼ご飯タイム
午前中のテストがなんとか終わって
ちょっとひと段落してお昼ご飯でございます。
母ちゃんが作ってくれた弁当・手作り。
はじめ頑張れ!!はじめ頑張れ!!ってこうきっと朝から頑張って作ってくれた弁当だったんですよ
”ありがとう母ちゃん、俺頑張るよ!!”そう思って母ちゃんの弁当食べようと思って開けた瞬間!!
ママーーーーーー！！！！
センター試験、高校で受けるわけじゃないんですよ
富山県中の高校生が会場に集まって受けるセンター試験だったんで
弁当食う控え室はもう他の高校、他の知らない人ばっかりの中で
僕は手で卵焼きとか食べてたわけですよ
・・・
もうその時点でだいぶメンタルはやられたんですけども
いや美味しかったよ母ちゃん、美味しかったよありがとう!!
富山県ってもう寒いんすよ冬は。
結露しちゃってるんで
廊下とかも凍ったりしてて滑るんですよね..あぶない。
滑るんですけど僕、トイレとかしてて遅れちゃって、
会場にいる200人くらいの生徒は皆着席してるんですよ静かに。
で、”やばい！皆座ってる！”と思ってこう走って会場に入って
自分の席まで行こうとした瞬間
床が結露してて滑って
アニメみたいなこういう倒れ方
頭からこうやって倒れました
ドュワ～ン
だ～れも笑わなかったし
皆なんにも面白そうじゃなかった
そりゃそうですよね、自分の進路・人生懸かってるわけですから
僕一人が静かな空間で200人の前で転んでも誰も何も笑われないですよそりゃ
それがあって一皮むけたのかしんないんけども
どうにでもなれって思って
その後は割とリラックスしてセンター試験を受けることができたというお話でございます
どうだ！200人の他人の中で頭から滑ってコケる奴なんてそういないだろう
で、もう一つちょっとすごいのがあったんですけども
センター試験で英語の科目があるじゃないですか
で、センター試験受ける人って高校3年生の人ばっかりじゃなくて
浪人生の方とか大人の方とか色～んな人がセンター試験をその会場で受けてたんですけども
僕の前の席にいた女の女性の方が
何歳なんだろうな
多分30歳くらいの女性だったんですけど
英語の試験始まった時にですね
なんかなんか試験官が2,3人くらいいたんですけど
全員、僕の前の席の女性のとこに集まってきて
”やっべ、この女まさかやらかしたか？”みてーな
カンニングでもバレたんじゃねーかと思ったんですけど
どうやらそうじゃなかったみたいで
高校生は皆、制服着てセンター試験受けるんですけども
一般の女性の方は自分の私服で来てるわけじゃないんですか
私服にね英語で単語が書いてあったんですよ
なんて書いてあったっけ
ジャスティス（justice）みたいな
ライトみたいな単語が書いてあったんですけども
それがどうやら不正だと思われたらしくて
センター試験の英語ってヒントになるようなのこと一切禁止なので
英単語書いてある服着てたらダメなんですよ
これ覚えといてください一般の方
その女の人英語のセーター着てたんで
英語のセーターﾄﾞｳﾓｳ脱ぐとほぼ裸の状態だったんですよ
女の人もセンター試験、裸で受けるわけにもいかなかったので
どうするんだろうと思って僕ずっと前でこうやって話し聞いてたら
服を裏返しにしてくださいみたいな
英語が見えることがダメだったみたいで
結果的にその人...英語書いてあったセーター裏返しに着て
セｗーｗタｗーwをｗこｗうｗやｗっｗて
裏返しに着せられてセンター試験受けてました
でですよ！後ろにいる僕の気持ち考えてくださいよ
後ろから見たら
首からこうやって札が見えてるわけじゃないですか
まじいい迷惑ですよ
なんで前の女の人セーター逆に着てセンター試験受けてるんだろうと思って
不覚にもめちゃくちゃ面白かったです英語の試験は。
まぁという感じかな僕のセンター試験は。
数学と国語で結構ミスっちゃって
結局、目標点より100点くらい低い点数になって
そっから志望校選びっていう感じで今の静岡大学になったんですけど
ま、静岡大学ー受ける時もね倍率がエグかったな
6.4倍かな
64人受けたら10人しか受からない枠だったんですけど
そこを無事勝ち抜き
無事、静岡大学に入れたという僕の大学受験でございました
本気で勉強してきた人は非常に緊張してると思います
合っててもバツになっちゃうことが本当に悲しいことなんで
センター試験は段ズレ、マークシートの段ズレだけ気を付けてください
胃が痛い日々が続きました僕も
緊張と不安で。
辛かった分良い未来が待ってると思います
大学行ったらもう好きなことできると思うんで
髪の毛だって金髪にでも茶髪にでもしてください。
是非
明るい未来に向かってもう一頑張りでございます
受験生の皆さん頑張ってください
良い結果を期待しております
じゃあな！